caleb is with us in dallas texas hey
Caleb welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call and
thanks for everything to you absolutely
how can I help
yes so my wife and I we are on kind of
baby steps 0.51 honors emergency fund
and have about 400 February but we
recently had a medical situation come up
and you know haven't been able to pay on
it and it went to collections and it's
now $82,000
so I was just curious what what kind of
advice you would have for us for how to
handle that you did not have health
insurance no health insurance why
because at that point we kind of told
her I've gotten a little bit smarter I'd
like to know and it's not my life side
of the gym I would but it just wasn't a
suitable for my wife and daughter to be
high yeah obviously that's a wrong
statement it was very affordable
compared to where you ended up that's a
- you know you couldn't afford not to
have it which is the case of everyone
okay so you have $82,000 do - what what
kind of a procedure that we actually in
the hospital for four days oh my god I'm
sorry when did that happen
bad-apple in July oh my goodness an
accident I know my wife is pastor says
oh I see in the pregnancy I see oh yeah
okay
and what is your household income my
salary is about 55 K and I burned
somewhere between about 18 to 25 of
commissions every year so somewhere
around so she work outside the home
okay here's what I'd do I'd schedule a
meeting in person and it may take you
several calls and some persuasion just
to get the meeting with some folks in
the administrative offices at the
hospital because most of the 82,000 is
the hospice
there's some other bills from other
people doctors or whatever lab reports
whatever but most of it is the hospital
probably 50 60 grand of the 80 to sit
down with them and first thing you tell
them is thank you for taking care of my
wife and walking with us through this
unbelievable tragedy we don't have
anything but good feelings towards you
guys for doing everything you're
supposed to do and I assume that's true
okay that is very okay I mean so you're
not coming in there to wave a finger at
them or to accuse them of anything that
you need to let get that off the table
real fast so start with gratitude and
just say thank you and then ask for
mercy and say we lost a child we're not
we got off we're in a fog I don't make
80 mm I don't have 80 mm what kind of a
deal can you cut me so that I can still
honor this bill but you can extend some
mercy to me and you will usually get the
deal of the century if you do that with
a proper attitude